I'm challenged both chefs to create one
exquisite course big amount of pressure
on their shoulders today because they've
got to develop and involve those dishes
into something stunning
I'm expecting a dish that's perfectly
spiced with delicious textures and
sublime flavors but it's not just me
they have to impress I've invited 20
guests who know their barges from their
brewery alleys to come and try both
restaurant dishes including anomaly
founder of the British curry awards and
respected Indian cookbook author and
broadcaster Manju Molly all my diners
will try both restaurants dishes each
restaurant front-of-house teams are here
as my guess and are we watching the
chef's every move and there's nowhere to
hide
okay first to go on it's for the
brilliance at four covers away Table six
yeah four gel Frazee okay sure
tonight the Brillion are taking on
Prasad at their own game cooking a
vegetarian take on a much-loved classic
paneer jalfrezi jazzy's recipe matches
chili laden Indian curd cheese with a
sauce flavored with a unique blend of 15
spices I'm making my own cheese today
WoW is that a bit crazy on a day like
today chef I'm in your restaurant after
whoo something crazy this is the type of
flourish just needs to live this classic
dish to new heights opportunities like
these never knocked on your doors that's
the reason why I'm working so hard I
want to achieve something today and I'm
excited to see sous chefs Anil making a
speciality rarely found in the UK
paper-thin Ramarley roti unorder the
brilliant four covers away Table one
guys look at me just like a normal
restaurant I need an answer
Thanks when you don't answer me I'm just
gonna stop and look at you again okay
cuz like you're doing your kitchen you
get a response but I'm calling out
tickets and no one's responding just
acknowledge what I'm saying right
otherwise I just go like this
[ __ ] it stick the tickets at then I've
got a call out for jalfrezi okay thank
you welcome back so far in this
competition
head chef jazz has produced some
stunning traditional Punjabi cuisine for
the brilliant
but on occasion he's lost control of the
kitchen his food has missed the mark and
owner Gullu has had to save the day
you got no good in the kitchen today you
don't need him in the kitchen do you
know you've got your work cut out eat
Sonia this is the biggest moment in our
history of the brilliant tonight the
hopes and dreams of the brilliant rests
on Jazz's shoulders okay stop the Appu
that yes sir stop look I can't sustain
it up it's just all so ya know just a
boy I've got the mayor of Ealing as that
energy we're serving food clinging on
like something coming out of a dude look
dog's [ __ ]
Table one let's go first dish coming
from brilliant thank you get your AC
with smells good you know like the
panniers nice and soft touch the chilies
got a kick Wow
mochi I'm not sure if I can see you then
I know it's thin enough